new york state's attorney general is
suing the national rifle association
to try and shut it down she accuses
long-time nra leader wayne lapierre and
other top officials of taking money for
their personal use
contributing to 64 million dollars in
losses a second lawsuit in washington
d.c
claims the nra's main charity misused
millions of dollars
jeff begaves looks at the alleged
misconduct
that enough was enough and we needed to
step in and dissolve this corporation
new york attorney general leticia james
claims
four top executives at the nra including
ceo
wayne lapierre used the powerful gun
rights advocacy group as a personal
piggy bank
her lawsuit alleges lapierre went to the
bahamas with his family by private air
charter on at least
eight occasions at a cost more than half
a million dollars to the nra
it also claims he spent more than 37
thousand dollars on a luxury private
hotel stay and was gifted complimentary
safaris in africa
it's clear that the nra has been failing
to carry out its stated mission for many
many years and instead has operated as a
breeding ground
for greed abuse
and brazen illegality in our race said
it would prevail in the dispute calling
the lawsuit
baseless and a transparent attempt to
score political points
the nra which has 5 million members has
been plagued by financial troubles
and leadership infighting after spending
roughly
30 million dollars to support president
trump in 2016
the group reported a 36 million dollar
deficit in 2018.
anna masolia with the center for
responsive politics says the nra
is spending considerably less this
campaign season
spending into the red three years
straight and so its prospects in the
2020 election
are much more cloudy the nra has
filed a counter suit against the new
york lawsuit which
president trump called terrible he also
suggested that the nra
relic relocate its headquarters to texas
vlad to be continued jeff begayes thank
you very much